as i'm sure most of you would guess i
don't typically wait around for the next
episode of tucker carlson's fox news
propaganda program but i actually was
curious as to what the program would
look like last night over the weekend as
we covered yesterday there was a
horrifying terrorist mass shooting
targeting black people in buffalo new
york in which
in total 10 people were killed and 13
injured the 18 year old white domestic
born shooter
inspired by the ideas of the great
replacement and white birth rates that
have been just everywhere on right-wing
media over the last few years the
shooter went to buffalo
looking to kill black people and indeed
he killed many black people and i was
waiting to see how is tucker carlson
going to spin it how is ben shapiro
going to spin it how is fox news going
to spin in well we immediately saw as we
looked at yesterday fox news talking
about video game violence
and continuing to fear monger about
terrorist immigrants coming over the u.s
mexico border so we saw the general fox
news approach but
the shooter's manifesto
had almost verbatim language that we saw
on the tucker carlson program so the
question was what's tucker going to say
and we're going to look at clips and it
was truly a surreal episode in
absolutely every way how was tucker
going to do it how is tucker going to
separate himself how was he going to
minimize well part of it bizarrely
included talking about rwanda if you can
believe it i'm talking about the african
country of rwanda a completely i can't
think of a better term for it
kafka-esque episode of the tucker
carlson program so let's start with the
first clip in which tucker
tries to distance himself
as well as fox news from the buffalo
shooter who was of course inspired by
the conspiracy theories that tucker and
others have been pushing take a look at
this
but what he wrote does not add up to a
manifesto it's not a blueprint for a new
extremist political movement much less
the potential inspiration for a racist
revolution
anyone who claims that it is is lying
well if you read it you realize that
that's exactly what it is it's taking
the conspiracy theories that tucker and
others have been repeating on their
programs
and saying well the solution is we've
got to go and kill people who aren't
white and that's what he did read it
instead gendron's letter is a rambling
pastiche of slogans and internet memes
some of which flatly contradict one
another the document is not recognizably
left-wing or right-wing it's not really
political at all that's obviously
completely untrue because it aligns with
the exact political ideology espoused by
those
surrounding donald trump
and on this so-called
populist right where they sound all
about the middle class but then the
solutions are well we've got to do
something about these non-white
immigrants coming into the country the
document is crazy it's the product of a
diseased and organized mind and remember
to some degree we can say there's
something mentally not working with
these folks
but as i mentioned before yesterday
the
manifesto
is quite cogent and coherent as far as
these manifestos go and writing this off
as simply mental illness doesn't make
any sense and remember most mentally ill
people never commit any violence at one
point gender suggests that fox news is
part of some global conspiracy against
him
he writes like the mental patient he is
disjointed irrational paranoid
now that's true not that it makes the
atrocities he committed easier to bear
if your daughter was murdered on
saturday in buffalo you wouldn't care
why the killer did it or who he voted
for
but the truth about peyton gendron does
tell you a lot about the ruthlessness
and dishonesty of our political
leadership
within minutes of saturday's shooting
before all the bodies of those 10
murdered americans had even been
identified by their loved ones
professional democrats had begun a
coordinated campaign to blame those
murders on their political opponents
they did it they said immediately patron
gendron was the heir to donald trump
okay so listen i am sympathetic to the
fraught nature of immediately making
political declarations that's why often
with these cases i won't cover it the
next day in this case it happened on a
weekend so we had time to the extent
that anybody before we had information
made any claims that weren't yet based
in fact that's wrong and i would
denounce that i didn't actually see that
but i also didn't pay attention to the
news on the day of i read about
everything after the fact but
the manifesto can be seen
only as an almost verbatim reproduction
of the things we've heard from tucker
and from other right-wing media now as i
mentioned earlier at one point
tucker talked about rwanda he put up a
quote from 2004 new york times about
rwanda and the rwandan genocide just i
mean completely bizarre bizarre stuff
and that
at another moment tucker again focused
on the this was just a lone mentally ill
guy that's it because a mentally ill
teenager murdered strangers you cannot
be allowed to express your political
views out loud
that's what they're telling you that's
what they've wanted to tell you for a
long time but saturday's massacre gives
them a pretext to justification so
playing on the idea that all of a sudden
now because of one mentally ill guy
completely disconnected from any
political rhetoric i mean other than the
fact that the manifesto contains
verbatim rhetoric from my show
me being speaking as tucker here
what really this is about is about
silencing your political views imagine
being so depraved or dishonest or
ignorant i don't know which it is with
tucker
to pretend that what this is really
about is simply silencing the political
speech of people like tucker who just
want to give their opinions now again
this thing of mentally ill when you look
at the manifesto
it's articulate
fascist
racist anti-semitic hate
linked to ideas that we've seen
propagated by tucker and others which we
will look at again later in the show
something is obviously wrong with people
who commit these acts of violence but
the mental illness the merely mental
illness line used to excuse the
political reality of these people's
motivations is immoral
and or dishonest
and maybe just ignorant but i have a
hard time believing that with tucker
it's ignorance so a bizarre tucker
carlson show
almost as bizarre
as what ben shapiro had to say which
we're going to go to next
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chili sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the dock pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60. their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get 30 percent off of the
uhler and cube sleep systems and 10
off the new dock pro this offer is only
for my audience the link is down below